[Musique]
le sénat a examiné la proposition de loi
visant à consolider notre modèle de
sécurité civile et valoriser les
missions de sapeurs pompiers plusieurs
dispositifs de ce texte ont été
confortés par le sénat le texte
adopté contient de nombreux amendements
du sénat et des avancées certaines est
très fort qui était attendu par nos
sapeurs pompiers et par nos élus des
territoires
le sénat a souhaité aller beaucoup plus
loin sur deux dispositifs en particulier
qui correspondait à des attentes fortes
du terrain le premier point c'est la
requalification a posteriori des
carences ambulancière ce sujet la
détermine le moment où les sapeurs
pompiers pour le compte 2 et à la
demande du samu interviennent lorsque il
s'agit d' urgence on s'aperçoit une fois
la course si je puis dire réaliser que
ces interventions là ne sont pas du
ressort de l'urgence à ce moment là il
faut que le samu puisse justement
rembourser les sapeurs-pompiers du
montant de cette course ça c'était
important parce que ce qu'on appelle le
titre le secours à personnes représente
80% de l'activité de nos sapeurs
pompiers dans ces transports là il y a
bon nombre de carences ambulancière donc
bon nombre de transports non urgents qui
représente un volume financier important
et qui pèse de plus en plus lourd dans
les budgets de nos services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
le deuxième point c'est
l'expérimentation de plateformes
communes que les forces de secours et de
sécurité puissent sur un plateau commun
travailler ensemble avec à l'issue d'une
période d'expérimentation que nous avons
fixée à deux ans un bilan qui sera
effectué et puis pour pouvoir évoluer
dans 1 2 même temps vers un numéro
unique qui serait le 112
[Musique]